lancer le nom plus grande richesse
pourtant de nombre relaxante aujourd'hui
en danger si bien que des citoyens et
des scientifiques tire la sonnette
d'alarme la relation des humains combiné
au changement climatique pourrais
hypothéquer d'ici 30 à 40 ans l'avenir
même de notre au potable
[Musique]
le Canada possède la plus grande réserve
d'eau douce au monde
plus d'un million de lac dans 700000 au
Québec
c'est naturel nous rendre de grands
services maison de plus en plus menacé
il y a quelque chose
dans le fait que on est un pays de lac
mais on est très très peu de ressources
même si ça fait partie de notre identité
les changements climatiques sont en
cause mais il y a aussi l'empreinte
humaine
on détruit l'environnement à tout point
de vue pour toutes les espèces qui
vivent les humains et le pire c'est que
cette détérioration s'accélère
des lacs ça change toujours mais c'est
la rapidité avec laquelle les
changements arrivent actuellement ça a
jamais arrivé dans le passé c'est
ça qui t'inquiète
[Musique]
Yannick et océanographe et limnologie il
s'intéresse particulièrement à la vie
organique des lacs
sa mission établir le bilan de santé de
plus de 650 lacs à travers le pays
aller chez le Canadien de savoir comment
il se porte et la clope les régions il y
a beaucoup d'agriculture c'est les
régions les l'accent sont beaucoup plus
endommagé donc ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui ressemble fortement dans nos
dans nos données
[Musique]
bassin versant de la quand il y a plus
de 30 % de terre qui se forme Agricole
on commence avoir des changements on
commence à avoir de la qui est altéré
les premiers résultats de l'étude sont
alarme dans 90 pourcents des la
canaliser il note la présence de
pesticides et d'autres agents chimiques
or trouver des poilus un des la majorité
des lacs au Canada donc ça on voit ça
même les la qui sont éloignés on trouve
les poilus
qui a les déchets humains qui peuvent se
rendre au lac chemin
[Musique]
en voyant ces canards pas ton j'ai dansé
ton visqueuse on pourrait croire qu'il
nage dans un petit étang et pourtant ils
sont sur un plan d'eau de 2 km carré de
la croix occitane en esprit
nom des lacs les plus mal-en-point au
Québec
au départ ici c'était tout des chalets
et il y avait des système d'installation
cette ce qui était associé
les gens sont devenus permanent et
Lester mais tu es plus performant il y a
plusieurs installation septique et qui
était non conforme certaines et avait
seulement une journée pour accueillir
aller au Lac dans la dans les pires
en 2015 toutes les installation septique
ont été raccorder au réseau d'égouts
municipal un bon pas pour
l'environnement mais qui ne sera pas
suffisant pour sauver le lac
[Musique]
des décennies de sur fertilisation ont
eu ton effets dévastateurs les plantes
envahissantes se sont mises à proliférer
[Musique]
2 chaussée de la mairie au fil de l'eau
des
plantes aquatiques
enracinées
et ben c'est sûr que c'est l'endroit
idéal il y a des nutriments c'est pas
profonde en cas de la lumière
le problème c'est que depuis 2006 le lac
Roxton est gavé de nutriments c'est ce
qui lui donne cette couleur verte
son niveau de phosphore est bien
au-dessus de la norme admise le
facilement
15 fois trop de passions dans la classe
qui devrait en avoir
Yves prairie à
UGC et professeur à l'UQAM depuis plus
de 30 ans il s'intéresse au processus de
transformation des plans d'eau
aujourd'hui Daniel la France en
Résidence du Lac la même constater les
changements qui a fait le plan d'eau
depuis 10 ans il le voit dépérir le lac
vieillis prématurément
il devient eutrophe donc très riche en
nutriments comme le phosphore
on veut avoir un sol fertile on veut
avoir des forêts fertile les lacs c'est
l'inverse on veut pas qu'il soit fertile
et on veut pas qu'il y a beaucoup
d'éléments nutritifs dedans en
particulier le façon donc c'est vraiment
faut penser comme le contraire de ce
qu'on pense au milieu terrestre
l'augmentation du phosphore est liée à
une multitude de facteurs
sont très belles ici alors j'ai
l'impression que la vente de fertilisant
d'engrais et pour le moment assez bonne
dans les environs
un petit pot d'un grain qu'on achète
c'est l'équivalent de ce que
de forêt vole au lac dans un de façon
naturelle
depuis 13 ans la biologiste Caroline
Bisson analyse la qualité du plan d'eau
et ses affluents
elle a constaté que c'est par les trois
princes pour Huisseau qui alimente le
lac qui arrive une grande partie du
phosphore
c'est finalement le plus gros critères
de la Crau sommes à peu près le tien de
tout le bassin versant pense parce que
c'est le truc où on ne l'est plus autour
de passeport qu'on enregistre est-ce que
c'est surtout des terres agricoles
les agriculteurs je pense sont
confrontés aux aléas de la nature et
pour pas prendre de chance d'un en grès
leur terre sur fertile juste pour être
sûr de pas manquer le porte unité que
cette année ils vont pouvoir faire de
bonnes récoltes
les bandes riveraines des ruisseaux en
milieu agricole et celle de la Croix
Stone sont en partie dénudée de
végétation
elles peuvent donc difficilement filtrer
tous ces nutriments le phosphore Percoll
alors dans l'eau des sols puis ruisselle
vers le lac
les bandes riveraines c'est quand qu'on
aimerait imposer aux soins mais on est
plus libéral envers les agriculteurs
parce que là on exige 3 m et je pense
que c'était une contradiction là
et tu le phosphore drainer vers les lacs
favorisent la propagation de plantes
envahissantes
ces nutriments stimule aussi l'éclosion
de colonies de cyanobactéries qu'on
appelle algues bleues
[Musique]
ce sont des bactéries mais on peut les
pensées comme des Halles combien un
autre c'est vraiment les microscopique
en suspension
lorsqu'un l'accès dégradé deviens les
cyanobactéries prennent la place des
autres organismes végétaux donc elles
vont pousser plus rapidement elles vont
dominer la communauté donc on va se
retrouver avec beaucoup de
cyanobactéries et moins des autres
espèces donc c'est vraiment ce qui se
passe c'est son meilleur à
compétitionner pour les nutriments dans
ces conditions-là les cyanobactéries ont
aussi détériorer la qualité et
l'oxygénation du plan d'eau ici
aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être pas le pire exemple du
Québec mais on n'est pas loin dans un
terme de niveau de pulsations on est
vraiment très très haut
Voici un autre problème pour le lac la
migration saisonnière des oies blanches
dans les fientes sont une source
importante de phosphore contenu de leur
grand nombre à chaque fois on se
demandait
parce que ça ça pourrait expliquer
l'augmentation
en 2005 et 2015
[Musique]
la surabondance de cyanobactéries a
d'autres conséquences pour les riverains
[Musique]
avec tout ce phosphore qui continue de
s'accumuler dans leur lac les arriverai
se demande comment ils pourront le
sauver
si on fait rien si les à part de façon
continue d'être aussi grand qu'il s'en
il va rester comme ça il reviendra pas
tout seul ça c'est certain
mais c'est un processus qui est
réversible si on prend les actions pour
[Musique]
après la pose des lacs où pullulent les
cyanobactéries
[Musique]
le lac Roxton a déjà été un grand
marécage avant la construction de ce
barrage au début du 20e siècle
sont neutres fixation rapide fait
resurgir des profondeurs c'est gros lots
éphémère
durant quelques semaines Sesamath
végétation demeure dans surface puis
disparaissent
avec tous ces choses-là c'est sûr que
c'est du vieux seul forestier qui est
quand on monte le niveau du lac pour en
faire un plus grand lac mais ça a tout
était en noyer puis le sac d'école c'est
ça ça c'est sûrement dû des des bulles
de méthane
pour bien mesurer l'état de santé dans
lac il existe un autre indicateur très
important le taux d'oxygène dans
la mais c'est aussi une bonne éducation
de ce qui se passe dans un lac
en
contact avec l'atmosphère la couche de
surface est plus chaude éclairé et bien
oxygénée la couche intermédiaire plus
mince et tempéré elle contient peu
d'oxygène
quant à la couche de fond elle est
froide faiblement t'éclairer il n'y a
presque plus d'oxygène
lac
trop fier quand il y a beaucoup d'armes
dans un l'accès à Glover se retrouve
dans le fond du lac et le les
organisations du lac consomme les and
utilise de Paris
et à ce moment-là il y a moyen que
j'aille les organismes peut plus vivre
parce que pour les poissons les truites
sont besoin de
à cause du manque d'oxygène le phosphore
du lac Roxton se libère des sédiments il
s'ensuit alors un phénomène de tout
fertilisation le lac s'alimente du
phosphore lâcher et accentue sa propre
trophies à Sion c'est à ce moment-là que
les cyanobactéries se multiplient
la façon on va libérer décidément il
doit entraîner une auto-alimentation une
auto fertilisation du lac car la façon
de façon interne dans lequel clairement
une source interne
[Musique]
pour se débarrasser de tout ce phosphore
il existe peut-être une solution et elle
se trouve à 25 km du lac Roxton au Lac
Brome en Estrie
[Musique]
Le Lac Brome on est un petit plan d'eau
de nuit kilomètre carré
durant plusieurs années il y avait ici
des problématiques similaires au lac
Roxton
l'association des riverains fait appel à
la biologiste de l'ours plan as
spécialisé en écologie aquatique
la température la concentration
d'oxygène dans toute la colonne d'eau
tous les éléments
pour la rivière
on a découvert que les nutriments dans
le lac 1
2006-2007 ne venait pas seulement des
apports de la chercheuse démontre que
plus de 80 % du phosphore est concentrée
dans les sédiments du lac
certaines solution plus ou moins drastic
ont été envisagé
dans le
mail
[Musique]
alors la biologiste propose d'utiliser
un nouveau produit
j'ai payé fais avec commendation en
fonction de les caractéristiques de
l'agrément
c'est là que j'ai recommandé
entraînement de dents produit qui peut
recouvrir les fonds et que je suis
proche a des choses naturelles qui a
calé phosphore retourne vers le haut
la solution est une technique de captage
de phosphore le phoslock
selon la biologiste ce produit
australien et non toxique pour les
humains et les organismes aquatique
qui était
séquestré mais c'est pour ça qu'il a
parce que tu as une solution qui était
intéressante pour nous
[Musique]
à l'automne 2017 174 tonnes de 7
substances ont été pendu dans le petit
lac de première au Québec
le produit est composé de granules
d'argile et de métal le lantane
dans la colonne d'eau il attire le
phosphore comme un aimant et l'entraîne
vers le bas
une fois dans le fond du lac le métal
non toxique recouvre les sédiments est
emprisonné si le phosphore
mais le produit coûte très cher
650000 dollars pays par la Ville de
Bromont
déconcentration de 70 % en profondeur
est ce qui nous manque qu'elle fasse le
fonctionne tes fils traitement ça va
assez bien tellement bien que à cause de
la transparence de l'eau il est
maintenant possible de mieux observer la
faune aquatique du lac
très satisfait mais
il faut attendre 5,10 ans
si tu continues pareil
Oh la classe on s'intéresse à
l'expérience du lac Bromont c'est
pour la crotte donc comme la nôtre
c'est
important je pense que ça peut être une
solution
mais si on fait rien aux intrants parce
que ils vont me lisez le façon à la
surface des sentiments mais si on change
rien aux entrant
[Musique]
sur de plus grande superficie
car aujourd'hui des centaines de pays
sont affectés par l'activité humaine et
les bouleversements climatique sa sœur
parce qu'on ne comprends pas
complètement c'est l'amplitude de ces
dégradations comment ça va être
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire dans les lacs
son on comprend pas les détails de ces
choses-là mais on sait que il va y avoir
une dégradation à cause des changements
climatiques impossible de pas avoir de
changement
l'avenir même des bassins d'eau potable
et en jeu
[Musique]
après la pose la source d'eau de la
ville de Québec sur haute surveillance
[Musique]
on la tient souvent pour acquise l'eau
potable est essentielle à notre survie
[Musique]
pourtant plusieurs de nos gestes de nos
décisions ont des impacts majeurs sur la
qualité des sources d'eau potable
CK à Québec un plan d'eau long de 5 km
et demi le lac Saint-Charles
même si ce réservoir constitue la
principale prise d'eau potable de la
région il faut encore aujourd'hui
convaincre les citoyens de l'importance
de le maintenir en santé
[Rires]
donc de vouloir protéger une prise d'eau
pour 301 personnes à part de Québec le
défi est énorme parce que les gens
disent allez vous trouver un autre
réservoir
[Musique]
pour nous
[Applaudissements]
Mélanie des lance on est à la tête d'un
regroupement de nettoyer vous et à la
protection du lac et de son bassin
versant le groupe à Giraud
commencer tranquillement dans les 4050
dernières années à prendre du poids le
prix et beaucoup d'éléments qui ont été
apportées au lac de développement
seul
entre 2007 et 2012 ce réservoir d'eau
potable a connu un vieillissement
accéléré
l'activité humaine et le développement
urbain en affecté la qualité
bien que son état soit stable
aujourd'hui il demeure tout de même
préoccupant
dans son bassin versant il y a encore
deux mails installation septique non
conforme
faut vraiment raccorder plus possible et
comme c'est la solution puisque on peut
pour accorder mais il faut bien les
comment
changer les installation septique pour
les meilleurs technologie
[Musique]
en théorie c'est facile mais en pratique
c'est plus difficile de convaincre les
citoyens d'apporter les modifications
exigée
en arrivant consultation publique ne
[Musique]
sont pas
de la technologie existante
Sonia BM elle est spécialiste des
ressources en eau au lac Saint-Charles
et les citoyens à mieux comprendre les
enjeux auxquels le lac est confronté
est la forme entre autres les citoyens
sur ce qui est dommageable pour l'eau du
lac comme se murer d'enrochement
c'est Pierre agiscom des calories faire
je rentre jour les pierres absorbe la
chaleur du soleil puis la transfert au
zoo du lac la nuit ce qui contribue à la
dégradation du plan d'eau
à 4 mètres
21. 28 degrés depuis plusieurs années
Sonia B mail suite après la qualité de
l'eau du lac Saint-Charles la tâche est
imposante j'ai besoin de connaissance
sur les la qui sont une source d'eau
potable est différente et plus important
qu'un lac qui ça là par exemple dans un
lac qui alimente une source d'eau
potable on va établir l'intégrité
écologique analyser tout contaminant qui
pourrait avoir un impact dans le
traitement de l'eau potable
[Musique]
l'échantillonnage est primordial on va
le prendre à plusieurs endroits à
plusieurs profondeur et en plus on va
ajouter davantage de paramètres
physico-chimiques
[Musique]
on va aussi chercher des échantillons
pour une analyse des cyanobactéries au
laboratoire pour savoir c'est quoi la
composition de la communauté sur le
bactérienne dans la laque
les résultats d'analyse confirme que le
plan d'eau est mal-en-point
dans la couche la plus profonde du
réservoir on est un manque d'oxygène
prononcer les cyanobactéries se
multiplient sais bien que le lac
Saint-Charles à Saint au niveau de
pulsations préoccupant nous avons
toujours les deux et que la loi que vous
Lyon il me tarde mais c'est pas du tout
le cas
Warwick Vincent est une sommité mondiale
dans l'étude des lacs d'eau potable
le chercheur et un partenaire
scientifique du regroupement des
citoyens du Lac St-Charles je commence
le 30 ans et depuis peu de temps voir la
grande extinction de devoir bosser c'est
surtout pour voir
pour grande ville
de l'indifférence de plusieurs citoyens
à l'égard de la ressource
veux entre verbe
de compréhension
de
naissance
le lac Saint-Charles a néanmoins on a
tous majeurs sans nous a un temps de
séjour relativement court
il se vidange en moins d'un mois ce qui
est considéré comme très rapide
c'est le gros avantage pour le lac
Saint-Charles essaie de facteurs qui
influencent la bonne qualité d'eau mais
c'est pas
passer en raison des nombreuses
agression qui subit encore aujourd'hui
on voit que c'est loin sur beaucoup de
pression avec le avec les
autres
c'est tout
mais l'endroit qui préoccupe le plus le
gros Pajero c'est le bassin versant du
lac Saint-Charles
alimenter principalement par la rivière
des Hurons le bassin couvre une partie
du territoire de trois municipalité
Québec Lac Delage et
Stoneham-et-Tewkesbury
grâce à sa forêt dense le bassin versant
agit comme première véritable barrière
de filtration en retenant les nutriments
et polluants dans l'ensemble du bassin
dans la 2e 3e 4e ligne de protection
qu'on doit absolument tout faire pour
reboiser tout ce qu'on pourrait boisé
conserver au maximum le couvert
forestier
Mélanie des Longchamps des projets de
construction et de déboisement dans les
municipalités en allemand du plan d'eau
amplifie la dégradation de l'eau potable
comme le branchement par exemple en même
temps pour ouvrir des nouveaux quartiers
de venir
un autre phénomène est en train de
briser l'équilibre naturel de nos plan
d'eau les changements climatiques
déjà les températures plus douces à
l'ange la saison chaude et ça ce n'est
pas une bonne nouvelle pour nos lac donc
on est exposé
et malheureusement les
2200 jeunes
qui poussent dans lac dans la même
direction
et malheureusement c'est dans une
mauvaise
mets convaincre les acteurs des
municipalités et des ministères de
l'importance de ce réservoir d'eau
potable et épuisant
la gouvernance proprement de
Lac-Saint-Charles a toujours été souvent
que je suis un peu le chien mais un peu
fatigué
et de manger des coups
ailleurs au Québec on cherche aussi des
solutions pour stopper la dégradation de
lac d'eau potable
une lutte contre les sous science des
citoyens et une gouvernance passive et
engagée
après la pose dans la qualité de l'eau
potable repose sur les épaules de
bénévole
[Musique]
le lac Kénogami et la réserve d'eau
potable de 80 % de la population de
Saguenay
en langue innu Kénogami signifie lac non
on voit bien le plein dos et un sur une
longueur de 26 km d'Hébertville jusqu'à
Saguenay
c'est immense lac se déverse dans la
rivière Chicoutimi puis dans la rivière
au sable à Jean-Pierre là où se trouvent
les deux prises d'eau de la municipalité
[Musique]
policier à la retraite Michel Bergeron
MP3 son lac et avec raison il est
maintenant le président de l'association
de protection du lac Kénogami dans le
fond les pots des environnementalistes
aujourd'hui
Jimmy Bouchard les accompagne se
conseiller municipal a choisi la
politique pour faire bouger les choses
son objectif faire comprendre à ses
concitoyens que leur lac est en danger
donner mes informations
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que les 5 prochaines
années et rien qui se passe
depuis quelques années les embarcations
à moteur sont plus en plus nombreuses au
lac Kenogami
le beaucoup plus de bateau de gros
bateau de gros seadoo sa main et
intérieur à son
visage
Environnement tôt mais l'érosion des
berges sauce pour quelque chose qui vont
nous aider
pour mesurer l'impact de tout ce
va-et-vient Michel Bergeron fais des
tests de transparence à quelques
reprises durant l'été
tous les temps à Manosque
même si c'est un lac qui alimente des
sources d'eau potable
l'inspection et le suivi de la qualité
de l'eau repose presque entièrement sur
les épaules des bénévoles de
l'association
c'est très sortie de son sur la télé
gagner allez point GPS assez précis
tu peux
prendre le bateau
les échantillons recueillis par ces
bénévoles sont envoyés au réseau de
surveillance volontaire des lacs du
ministère de l'Environnement
l'association des riverains doit être
aussi des Freddy une partie de la
facture des analyses en laboratoire de
leur échantillon d'eau
[Musique]
le résultat de ses analyses des taux
élevé de trophies à Sion
parmi les hommes les plus endommagé la
baie cascouia et le lac du camp à
l'extrémité nord-ouest du lac
la transparence de l'eau dans ce secteur
durant l'été n'est pas de bonne augure
pour un réservoir destiné à la
production d'eau potable
mais le plus malin. C'est le secteur du
lac du KAC 3 et peu profond
plusieurs chalet des résidences en
dérive border d'enrochement
plus loin des plages privées ont été
aménagé
ici les bandes riveraines non tout
simplement pas la côte
malgré tout à l'heure bonne foi faire
bonne volonté souvent on peut commencer
qu'est-ce que ça peut faire comme
formation
autre phénomène la densité de la
population autour du lac augmente un
nombre croissant de retraités décide de
l'établir à demain des chalets se
transforme en résidence permanente
des maisons de plus en plus imposant
série j'ose à bord du lac on repousse
les terrains ont des vegetalise les
berges des ouvrages artificielles et des
parterre fleuri et gazonné se
multiplient
un autre problème majeur les
installation septique il y en a plus
d'un millier autour du lac mais il faut
aller plus loin ça faut que je vienne
comme ça il est plein tu
pourrais au moins 2 cartons de savoir
quel est l'état de
partout
à Saguenay on se demande d'ailleurs
pourquoi le ministère de l'Environnement
n'en fait pas plus pour protéger ce
réservoir d'eau potable une source
vitale pour la population
sont beaucoup plus porté sur nous dans
les différentes responsabilité sans les
moyens en fait qui viennent avec pour
parler demain c'est la réglementation
avec les municipalités sont obligé
d'appliquer installation c'est
nous qui doit appliquer sa
critique envers le ministère de
l'Environnement ne viennent pas
uniquement de Saguenay en 2020 la
vérificatrice général du Québec à
réprimander le ministère pour son
inaction
[Musique]
dans son rapport on peut lire comme
ministère de l'Environnement la gestion
des connaissances est inefficace et une
efficiente il permet pas de dresser un
portrait fiable de l'état de ses
ressources
puis il est écrit que le ministère ne
possède pas les connaissances lui
permettant d'assurer la gestion intégrée
des ressources en eau au Québec
plus loin on ajoute que ces lacunes
compromettre la conservation des
ressources en eau pour les générations
actuelle et future
on se voit ça pour faire respecter de
réglementation sur les bandes riveraines
c'est tout à fait correct pour nous
citoyens qui sont alors demande à faire
des efforts c'est pas grave on garde sur
la rive sud du lac une amie qui sont
fait
[Musique]
le principal affluent du lac Kenogami
c'est une coupe forestière comment on
les voit trop au Québec c'est une distri
la foresterie donc pour que ça soit
efficace moins coûteuse sur le court
terme c'est pour ça qu'on fait cette
tête de con
le ministère des forêts de la faune et
des parcs à justifier ses coupes à
Saintes contrer l'épidémie de tordeuse
des bourgeons de l'épinette
pour
le bois pour l'industrie forestière où
est-ce que c'est vraiment parce que
toute la forêt et maintenant c'est le
volume de coupe des matières organiques
facilement se déverser dans la rivière
des fragments d'arbres et de terre du
phosphore de l'azote et potentiellement
des métaux lourds
[Musique]
réagit avec les produits qu'on utilise
pour traiter notre
tu as gardé ici l'envoie très bien leur
ça va créer des petites rivières qui
vont passer sans obstacle important
directement la rivière directement dans
lac et sérieuse d'avoir plusieurs effets
néfastes sur le lac
d'ici mars prochain d'autres coupe
forestière sont prévus à l'embouchure de
la rivière picoba
à cet endroit il y a des panda brut et
avec les activités voirie forestière la
rivière pour être encaissé de course
selon la spécialiste
c'est les chemins forestiers qui m'ont
créé le plus de problème dès le
printemps ou même si on a maintenant là
souvent des périodes de nous on y va à
régler très forte pluie donc on risque
de avoir des coulées de boue important
vers le lac
tant qu'on veut éviter qu'ils aillent
des produits d'autres informations qui
se crée lors de la production d'eau
potable Lord à Décines section de 7 ans
et plus que l'eau est pure à l'entrée
moins quand on va avoir ses produits de
transformation et c'est pour ça qu'on
doit à tout prix protéger les sources
d'eau potable pour éviter qu'il y a des
mélanges de comme ça qui se font et qui
peuvent avoir des effets plus long terme
sur la santé
qu'est-ce qui pourrait les convaincre de
plus que la réserve d'eau potable de 80
% de la plus grande ville du
Saguenay-Lac-Saint-Jean
à mon sens c'est suffisant pour agir sur
la protection de celle-ci
s'il y a personne qui fait rien un jour
sur génération on va voir quels sont
plein d'eau
chapeau
ailleurs au pays d'autres associations
de riverains doivent composer avec les
mêmes préoccupations mais aussi les
mêmes menaces
l'intensification de l'activité humaine
autour des plans d'eau et l'accélération
des changements climatiques s'annonce
comme des défis de plus en plus
périlleux pour la préservation de leur
lac
parce que c'est une problématique à la
SPA et on peut pas c'est pareil il est
dans mes contacts le changement de
climat
moi c'est ça que je suis inquiète est-ce
que je sais c'est que les choses vont
se dégrader dans le futur
espèce de poisson dans certains lacs
parce que
dans 40 ans si la température du lac
d'Annecy le lac ne vient le trouve plus
qu'il est là il va avoir un effet direct
sur les contribuables de la qualité du
milieu de vie